تعرضت 24 منشأة طبية
للهجوم منذ بدء الحرب
وفقًا للأرقام الجديدة الصادرة عن منظمة الصحة العالمية ،
حيث أجبر أكثر من 2 مليون أوكراني على الفرار من
البلاد ، كما نزح ما يقرب من 2 مليون شخصًا
داخليًا بسبب
القصف المستمر الذي أدى أيضًا إلى
حدوث  لحظة من الهدوء الرائع
تحت
الضغط ، الفيديو الذي توشك على مشاهدته هو
لفريق خدمات الطوارئ الأوكراني في
تشيرنوهي وهو يزيل بحذر شديد
المفجر من قنبلة روسية غير منفجرة ،
تسمع طائرًا يزقزق بعيدًا في
الخلفية ،
دعنا نذهب إلى تقديرات الولايات المتحدة
أن الخسائر الروسية مرتين فقط
كانت الأسابيع في هذه الحرب كبيرة تصل إلى
10 في المائة من إجمالي قوتها إما
مدمرة أو غير قابلة للتشغيل ، وقد
زادوا بشكل كبير من تقديراتهم
لخسائر الموظفين الروس في وقت سابق من هذا
الأسبوع كانوا يقولون ما بين ألفين وأربعة
آلاف الآن يقولون ربما ستة
آلاف أعني  وهذا يرقى إلى
إجمالي عدد الوفيات في العراق
وأفغانستان على مدار 20 عامًا  فقط في
غضون أسبوعين هنا
ما هو
تقييمك لأداء
الجيش الروسي هنا حتى الآن
حسنًا ، شكرًا لك أه إنه
يقترب أيضًا من نصف
نقطة كل
خسائر الاتحاد السوفيتي في
أفغانستان
ما نشهده الآن  هي
قوة برية غير كفؤة بشكل غير متوقع
لم يتمكنوا من تنفيذ
مناورة الأسلحة المشتركة
ولا يمكنهم إعادة إمداد قواتهم البرية
مرة أخرى في الحرب الباردة كنا نشعر بالقلق
بشأن ارتفاع 10 أقدام روسي
آه نعم لم يظهر
في النهاية  من اليوم لنكون في
أي مكان قريب مما
فعلناه مرة أخرى ،
وقد قلل الروس
بشكل كبير من
تقدير عدوهم ، لقد
قللوا بشكل كبير من الصعوبة
والمناورة في أوكرانيا
، ونحن نرى أن ذلك يحدث يوميًا ،
أنا عالم أرصاد جوية تشاد  ألقى مايرز
نظرة على درجات الحرارة عبر
أوكرانيا شديدة البرودة ، حيث خرجت كتلة هوائية باردة
من الشرق وانتشرت
في درجات حرارة أقل بكثير من
المعتاد أقل من درجة التجمد.  في
كل منطقة تقريبًا هنا خاصةً في الليل ،
لن يكون هناك أي شك أقل من درجة التجمد
بالتأكيد تحت الصفر المئوي تحت 32
فهرنهايت حتى بالنسبة إلى كييف في الصباح
التي تبلغ 18 درجة فهرنهايت ، يمكنك تحويل
ذلك وستصبح أقل كثيرًا هناك في الجداول المئوية ، فأنت أقل بكثير من
الصفر
هنا خلال كامل الفترة التي تقوم
فيها بالإحماء إلى + واحد في keeve في يوم
السبت ، تبدأ الأمور في
التحسن قليلاً حيث نعمل من الأحد إلى
الاثنين ، لكن الأمر سيستغرق
وقتًا طويلاً حتى يغادر هذا الهواء البارد
البلد أخيرًا  العودة إلى أعلى من المعتاد في بعض
المناطق غير خاركيف على الرغم من خاركيف ، يمكنك الحصول
على علامة زائد واحدة في فترة ما بعد الظهر ، وهذا هو
اليوم الأكثر دفئًا لبقية الأسبوع ،
وهذا لا يحدث حتى يوم الأربعاء التالي
وهو أكثر دفئًا إلى الشرق حيث لا تكون
الرياح الشرقية الباردة '  الوصول لدرجة
الحرارة في الأربعينيات ، وبعض
المناطق أكثر دفئًا قليلاً من ذلك
خلال فترة ما بعد الظهر ، ولكن بالنسبة للأماكن
التي لا تحتوي على حرارة ،
فلا يوجد بها مأوى.
ستكون أيامًا قاسية جدًا على التوالي
لشعب أوكرانيا